we now know how to name aldehydes and
ketones and what I want to do in this
video is show a mechanism for actually
creating one and in particular we're
going to create a ketone so let's say
we've got ourselves some benzene and the
first step of this reaction the benzene
is just going to sit and watch we've got
some benzene and we've got some acetyl
chloride acetyl chloride so it looks
almost like an aldehyde or ketone but
instead of having a carbon chain here or
hydrogen we're going to have a clora a
chlorine atom right over there so this
is acetyl chloride acetyl chloride
sometimes called acyl chloride this is
acetyl chloride and we're going to have
an aluminum chloride catalyst and a
catalyst means that it participates in
the reaction but it enters the reaction
and it exits the reaction is the same
molecule so it just catalyzes it but it
doesn't disappear it just changes
halfway but then goes back to what it
was before so we have some aluminum
chloride and it's bonded to one two
three one two three chlorines now the
first step of this reaction is to turn
this acetyl chloride into a good
electrophile turn it into something
that's really good at nabbing electrons
so good that it can break the aromatisse
'ti of the benzene ring and essentially
add itself to the benzene ring this is
actually the same mechanism we saw with
I think electrophilic aromatic
substitution I always have trouble
remembering the names what I was
imagining it's electrophilic
substitution
either way it's this very similar
mechanism and actually that what we're
going to show in this video is called
friedel-crafts a salacious because this
right here this right here is called an
acyl group this right here is called an
acyl group and we're essentially going
to acyl eight the benzene ring we're
going to add this group right here to
the benzene ring so enough of what's
going to happen let's actually see it
happen so the first thing to realize
this aluminum chloride the aluminum in
it is electron deficient at a first cut
if you just look at the periodic table
if you look at the periodic table you
have these chlorines over here pretty
electronegative aluminum is in the same
row but chlorines way more to the right
so it's more electronegative so the
chlorines are going to hog the electrons
in this molecule the chlorines are going
to hog
so the aluminum is going to have a
partial positive charge chlorines
will have slightly partial negative
charge on top of that you see aluminum
is a group 3 is a group 3 element 1 2 3
so it has 3 valence electrons you see
that right here 1 2 3 nowhere close to
the magic number of 8 even when it
covalently bonds with these chlorines it
can only pretend like it has 6 electrons
it can kind of pretend like it has these
chlorines electrons over here but that
only gets it to 6 so it would really
like to have more electrons to get
closer to that to get closer to that
magic 8 number so what you can imagine
is is a situation where this chlorine
this chlorine on the acetyl chloride
this chlorine it's already hogging this
green electron from this carbon it was
already doing that it's more
electronegative so this thing over here
will actually be given to the aluminum
and so it will then have a bond with the
chloride so if that happened what is our
reaction look like so if that happened
what does everything look like our
aluminum our aluminum our aluminum
chloride or what was formerly aluminum
chloride now just gained an electron and
with it and with it it is now bonded to
another chlorine so it is now bonded to
a another chlorine and since it gained
an electron let me make it very clear
this is an L my penmanship is
deteriorating that's an L and since this
aluminum gained an electron it now has a
negative charge and normally a
negatively charged thing isn't that
stable but these guys are
electronegative so they might hog a lot
of that Elect of that negative charge
and on top of it aluminum can now
pretend like it has eight electrons it
has one two three four five six seven
eight when you Kaval covalently bond to
someone you can kind of pretend like you
have their electrons as well so now you
have this anion that was formed from the
aluminum chloride and now the acetyl
chloride the acetyl chloride will look
like this the acetyl chloride let's
scroll down a little bit let me make it
clear we're in the next step of the
reaction we are in the next step of the
reaction what was formerly the acetyl
chloride has now lost the chloride so
it's now really just a acyl group
so you have the carbonyl bonded to a ch3
a methyl just like that this guy lost
his electron so now he has a positive he
has a positive charge and this is
actually it's not that stable and you're
going to see it's actually highly
reactive it's a very good electrophile
it wants to steal other people's
electrons but it is it will it can exist
for a short amount of time especially
because it is resonant stabilizing so
how is it resonance stabilized
well this oxygen over here has two
electron pairs that I didn't draw before
and let me draw the second one in a
different color it has two electron
pairs like that so you could imagine a
situation the electron this guy this
carbon is already he has a positive
charge and this oxygen is more
electronegative is already hogging his
electrons maybe wants to give back a
little bit say hey this is positive
these electrons all the electrons are
hanging out here they'd be attracted to
the positive and you could imagine one
of these electrons being given back to
the carbon and if that happened if that
happened then we have another resonance
form we have another resonance form that
looks like this so this was our original
molecule or that's our original or what
it looked like we still have this double
bond right over there
but now this or that pair of electrons
now this pair of electrons now forms
another bond this electron over here is
now on the oxygen end this electron over
here is now on the carbon end and now
they have a now they have a triple bond
and what happened this positive carbon
gained an electron so it's now neutral
and the neutral oxygen lost an electron
so it is now positive and you can
imagine this is not a very stable that
you wouldn't see this just floating
around by itself but it does stabilize
this entire configuration it stabilizes
this molecule so you can show that these
are alternates resonance resonantly
stabilized structures right there but as
I said these aren't super stable this
guy really really really wants to react
and now this is where benzene comes into
the mix and actually let me draw a
little dividing line here just so we
know that this was a separate stage of
our reaction so that was the first stage
then we go over here and
now benzene comes into the mix the
benzene is floating around so we have
our benzene benzene floating around just
like that and then I'm going to draw one
of the hydrogen's on one of the
benzene's all of these car on one of the
carbons all of these carbons have
hydrogen's on them I just won't draw
them all it just makes things
complicated but this guy we said is a
really good electrophile and it's you
have to be a really good electrophile to
attract electrons from a benzene ring to
break its aromatisse ax t but if it
bumps or into this guy in just the right
way just the right angle you could
imagine that this electron on this
carbon right here gets swiped by the
acyl group gets swiped by the acyl group
so then what do we have so now I will go
I will go back in this direction so you
have what was a benzene ring so what was
a benzene ring
it still has we could draw the double
bonds here and here here and here and we
of course have this hydrogen we have
this hydrogen but now this bond which
was the double bond there is now bonded
to the acyl group so it has that blue
electron that the acyl group nabbed and
let me draw the acyl group and I'll flip
it over I'll flip it over so that we
have the methyl on the right-hand side
so it's a carbonyl bonded to a ch3 it
was positive it now gained an electron
it is now neutral it is now neutral this
carbon over here lost an electron so it
is now positive so it is now it is now
positively charged now we mentioned the
aluminum chloride is a catalyst so it
won't just sit around there as the anion
it has to go back to being aluminum
chloride so let's bring the aluminum
chloride back into the scene so we have
our aluminum chloride let me copy and
paste it copy and paste so we have our
aluminum chloride here and so you can
imagine that the benzene ring wants to
go back to being aromatic so this this
electron right here this electron right
here on the hydrogen
this electron right here on the hydrogen
might really want to go back to this
carbon right over here this carbo cation
and at the same time if the aluminum if
this anion now passes the hydrogen in
just the right at just the right angle
at the right time while this guy is
attracted to this carbon this chlorine
can give this green electron to the
hydrogen to the hydrogen nucleus which
is really just a proton and then the
hydrogen's electron can be taken up by
what was this carbo cation and then what
did we have then we have a situation
where our benzene ring is reformed we
have the aromaticity again we have that
double bond that double bond and now we
have this double bond again although now
it's using the electron from the
hydrogen and we still and now we've
substituted this hydrogen which is
essentially this acyl group this acyl
group right over here so we have a
carbon double bonded to an oxygen bonded
to a methyl group and now the aluminum
or this-this-this anion lost it's an
electron so it goes back to just being
straight-up aluminum chloride aluminum
it goes back to just being straight-up
neutral electron deficient aluminum
chloride and we've done we're done we've
just ASA lized this benzene ring and
that's why this is called this mechanism
is called friedel-crafts Friedel riedle
friedel-crafts crafts isolation
isolation and Friedel is actually a
former former president of MIT and i did
some reading on this and he apparently
he did not have a ph.d but because he
discovered friedel-crafts isolation and
this friedel-crafts actually alkylation
as well they said hey you know this
guy's a smart dude let's make him the
president of MIT but I just wanted to
show you that this is a reaction for
creating a ketone so this create this
this ketone that we've created is a seed
of fien own which we've seen before
which we learned in is a common name
this molecule that we learned in the
first ketone video and I'll write it in
purple Osito Osito be known and we're
done